PROFESSOR: All right.
So here is my public disclaimer
that will go on the video
so that no one will
judge you for having only
had one day to do this project.
They will be amazed at
how much you got done.
So we're going to present,
and no one's project
is completely finished,
so don't stress.
This is a thing that
you had one day to do,
and you will have three days and
a weekend to do the next one.
So this is just a practice
run, because next Friday you'll
have a much bigger project
and we'll invite other people.
So here is about supporting
and learning from each
others' process and learning
about what things you had
success with and what
things you didn't.
So if somebody was
able to implement
a lean, then afterward you go,
hey, how did you do that lean?
Can I have your scripts?
Or if somebody had
a cool gesture,
or if somebody had a nice
video game animation where
something grew and
something did something
in response to the
growth, you can ask them
how they implemented that.